cent vingt mille postes dans la fonction
publique emmanuel macron s'était engagé
à réduire de manière drastique le nombre
de fonctionnaires lorsqu'il était le
candidat dans marche cinquante mille
postes de fonctionnaires d'état devaient
être supprimés durant son quinquennat
ainsi que 70 mille postes dans la
fonction publique territoriale
à moins d'un an de la fin du mandat du
chef de l'état l'objectif a été
totalement abandonnée
interviewé sur la web télé acteurs
publics le ministre délégué chargé des
comptes publics a confirmé le changement
de cap il y a eu un certain nombre de
décisions qui ont été prises après le
grand débat en 2019 qui nous ont amenés
à revoir ses objectifs au delà des
décisions que nous avons prises après le
grand débat la crise s'est abattue sur
le pays et cela s'est traduit par des
créations de postes parce qu'il fallait
y répondre
toutes ces décisions nous les assumons
cela fait partie des réponses à la crise
et cela a modifié évidemment l'objectif
à l'échelle du quinquennat
nous avons collectivement avec le
premier ministre ou son autorité sous
l'autorité du président de la république
un objectif de stabilité des schémas
d'emplois à l'échelle du quinquennat
entre 2017 et 2022
un changement de cap déjà esquissé par
le chef de l'état lors de sa conférence
de presse d'après grand débat en 2019
j'assume totalement d'abandonner cet
objectif s'il n'est pas tenable de base
ces suppressions devait participer à la
réduction de la dépense publique de 3
points de pib comme le souhaitait et
emmanuel macron à gauche cet abandon est
plutôt bien accueillie maintenir cet
objectif aurait été criminel indique le
secrétaire national du pcf est candidat
à la présidentielle fabien roussel à nos
confrères du monde
à droite en revanche on le déplore comme
le rapporte le quotidien
pour la vice-présidente lr annie
genevard cette volonté de réduire le
nombre de fonctionnaires n'a jamais été
véritablement là puisque très peu de
suppressions de postes sont intervenus
avant la crise ce point n'est pas le
seul sur lequel emmanuel macron a fait
marche arrière parmi les sujets de recul
on peut citer l'interdiction du
glyphosate ou la limitation de vitesse à
80 km/heure et dernier rétropédalage en
date le référendum sur la réforme
constitutionnelle ayant pour but
d'inscrire la préservation de
l'environnement à l'article 1er de la
constitution
il n'aura au final
en pas lieu emmanuel macron s'était
pourtant engagé à le mettre en oeuvre